welcome back to rockstars i'm eric voss
and man of steel was zack snyder's
underappreciated
launch of a deeply thematic and often
misunderstood cinematic universe with
snyder's cut of justice league coming
out next year we
are re-exploring henry cavill's superman
arrival for the many visual
details easter eggs layers of meaning
some
not so subtle others very easy to
overlook under the layers of muscle
we open on krypton the birth of kal-el
the first
natural kryptonian birth in centuries
snyder designed the kryptonian
architecture in the art nouveau style
meaning that no design can be as
balanced as what nature creates and
snyder himself acknowledged that the
natural forms most reflected
are reproductive organs an ironic
expression of krypton's fertility crisis
and yeah kal-el's pod shooting out of
the hell homestead
is life finding a way
yep that is our first missable detail
brace yourselves now the superman sigil
in these films is the house of l family
crest and translates to hope
all kryptonians wear their family sigils
on their chests like this the idea being
that superman suit is really just the
common kryptonian undergarment with
krypton's core becoming unstable jor-el
begs evacuation i have held that hope
in my hand a clue for his encoding the
kryptonian genetic codec
into the cells of his newborn son the
literal
heir of hope jarrell stands up to zod
will sever the degenerative bloodlines
that led us to this state
and who will decide which bloodline
survives on
you russell crowe's eye line directs up
to zod's eyes
meaning that when he said the word
bloodlines he was glaring in judgment at
zod's clan chest emblem
then redirecting that judgment to the
face zod's sword of rayo crest has a
sickle shape like the scythe of death
ending in a fine point a contrast to the
winding flowing line of the el crust
which brings life
like like a river created by jerry
siegel and joe shuster
the family name l is a hebrew word for
god
a parallel snyder does not shy away from
you'll be a god to them cal is cast as a
christ figure over
and over and over and snyder does this
really to link superman to joseph
campbell's hero's journey the monomyth
hero with a thousand faces
you'll notice kryptonian glyphs are
everywhere actually on the opening
warner brothers logo but appearing on
the council chamber they translate to a
kryptonian
poem but according to snyder among these
glyphs is also a translated quote
from joseph campbell now you'll notice
looming over krypton is this shattered
moon
snyder recently revealed that this is
actually intended as a reference to a
past battle with doomsday this was
before he reintroduced doomsday as zod's
corpse resurrected and batman v superman
zod's warships approach in the heat of
the sun an homage to the right of the
valkyries and apocalypse now
a super iconic image it's not actually
in that film but on its poster
now man of steel as a film has a lot of
concepts at play christ allegory
reproductive symbolism
greek philosophy but at its heart it was
intended by the filmmakers to be
an immigrant story now this isn't new to
anyone who's read superman comics or
explored his mythology but
this film more than others focuses on
kal-el as an undocumented alien
in hiding hopping from job to job hoping
that authorities will see him as someone
here to help
not replace i grew up in kansas general
about as american as it gets
young clark panics from his overwhelming
senses and martha tells him
to make the world smaller
[Music]
just um
focus on my voice composer hans zimmer
in this moment
simplifies it all down to the mere basic
piano melody of this superman theme
reflecting clark tuning out the world's
distractions
to bring himself home to his core value
of hope
and editing syncs this song with the
whale song that wakes up clark in the
water
some theories suggested that those
whales were sent by aquaman snyder
acknowledged it as a cool idea but not
necessarily when he intended
after saving smallville school kids pete
ross and lana lang
pete's mom casts him again as a
religious figure i'm sure what he
thought he saw
was an act of god jonathan this was
providence
lana saw it too and the fordham board
and she's referring to whitney fordham
one of the jockstew later bullies clark
but he's based on whitney fordman
lana lang's smallville boyfriend pocket
suggests clark
might sometimes have to let people die
to hide a secret foreshadowing his own
death but clark says
can i just keep pretending i'm your son
you are my son
an exchange taken from the superman
secret origins comic clark
first greets lois lane by lifting her
out of the helicopter catching her as he
will again catch her in the future
and welcoming her to something near his
home turf of the kryptonian scout ship
as she will later do for him in the
final scene welcoming him
to the daily planet i love how you can
see all of that right here in this
little greeting she meets dr emil
hamilton who in the comics is a
scientist from star
labs alongside future dcu characters
like cyborg's father
silas stone and it looks like in the
justice league snyder cut
ray palmer the atom now this ancient
kryptonian scout ship has left
one cryopod open a hint by snyder that
there could be
another kryptonian out there somewhere
but rather than confirming it could be
supergirl kara zor-el snyder just left
it as a general loosen that he might
come back to later one of the
observation monitors shows
the surface of mars which snyder said
was intended to be a nod to dr manhattan
from his previous film watchmen but he
said that actually showing manhattan
would be too much
too much dick perry white won't run
lois's story so she leaks it to woodburn
whose name is an amalgamation of
watergate reporters woodward and
bernstein
jor-el's projection recounts krypton's
history via shape-shifting engravings
which were based on real-world
greco-roman sculptures
with those lost classic influences also
inspiring kryptonian social engineering
every child was designed to fulfill a
predetermined role in our society
as a worker a warrior leader so
this was inspired by plato's republic
which clarke actually could be seen
randomly reading later in a flashback
see plato preached that the most just
society sorted everyone into functions
based on their compositions at birth
very rigid social structure that
immigrants all over the world over the
centuries
have sought to break free from you're as
much a child of earth now
as you are of crypto you can embody the
best of both worlds
now the flight test is narrated by jorel
paraphrase from grant morrison's words
in all-star superman
you will give the people of earth an
ideal to strive towards
they will race behind you they will
stumble they will fall
but in time they will join you in the
sun cow clark tells lois about his
father's death via tornado showing how
this superman and zack snyder's universe
will sometimes lose people to forces of
nature
although he totally could have saved him
i mean just like super fast the [ __ ]
tornado is anyone gonna really notice
so by the way highway overpass is not
safe to hide under during a tornado
anyway the first of many avoidable dceu
casualties that we will discuss in an
upcoming big question clark returns to
the kent farm from a lex corp truck
lex corp actually shows up all over this
movie setting up lex luthor's entry to
this universe in the next film
you gotta look carefully because these
details could be hiding in plain sight
like i bet you didn't know that i had a
ridge wallet in my hand
because actually i didn't it's on my
head thanks for playing thanks to the
ridge for sponsoring this episode
the ridge helps you carry what you need
every day from their flagship ridge
wallet to their portable charging
commuter backpack they want to make the
most out of what you're bringing with
you the ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
or carbon fiber it has a clean
stylish design and we've learned it as
chainsaw proof tested on our intern
craig
may he rest in pieces this is their
forged carbon fiber wallet they have
other colors including some very flashy
tiki designs
it's light it's strong it's like a pisco
from coal mine
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee it's got thirty thousand five
star reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets optional device
charging batteries get 10
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going to rich.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description sullivan's tractor
repair is a nod to chloe sullivan
originally from the smallville series
later brought into the comics
oh wait alison mack goddammit can we get
one retro breakdown where the caster
crew isn't later revealed to be a
criminal along with whitney fordham the
other bully is ken
braverman kenny braverman of comics is a
smallville kid exposed to kryptonian
radiation
becomes a super villain conduit adult
clark chats with father leone
a recurring confident from the comics
since 2004 and behind clark is the not
at all subtle stained glass showing
jesus in gethsemane
the moment jesus decides whether to
sacrifice himself to save humanity as
clark is about to do here
general swanwick is the one official not
to back up when superman breaks the
cuffs and approaches the glass that
might be because zack snyder later
revealed that he planned for this guy
to be the dceu's martian manhunter a
backstory we might see
in the snyder cut according to some
hints from actor harry linux and the
communication officer behind hamilton in
the shot is a cameo by aaron smalinski
who as a kid played the child version of
kal-el in the original richard donner
superman and cameoed in two and three
zod explains to superman how they
escaped the phantom zone by retrofitting
the
phantom drive into a hyperdrive and so
the instrument
of our damnation
became our salvation he also says that
they only found earth because
khalil activated the distressed beacon
from this scout ship
you led us here cap so ironically
the instrument of cow's salvation became
his damnation now this projected image
of superman sinking into the field of
skulls is a bit dramatic not a very good
idea if zod wants cal to join him
schneider said that he wanted to reflect
the worst possible fate for superman
being unable to stop the deaths of
everyone around him
superman fights zod's commanders in
smallville this action was shot with
handheld rigs
shaky pants quick zooms a naturalistic
documentary style so that they had to
animate the fighting kryptonians to the
camera
even if that means they aren't cleanly
in every frame actually looks kind of
cool to see what it would look like from
a ground-based tv news crew filming this
the only problem is this rule gets
broken later when superman fights zod
like you can't have a tv
news group floating around them in the
air that might be part of the reason
you might not emotionally attach to that
later fight nomak jumps on a jet and
rips off the pilot's head causing his
blood to spray everywhere
actually if you listen very closely you
can hear this pilot's final words
echoing over smallville
now the smallville storefronts are
filled with easter eggs
otto's barbershop is a not to auto
binder creator of supergirl brainiac
crypto the dog and the phantom zone
pap's pizza shout out to george edward
papp superboy artist
ezra's mail depot is an autumn
smallville town founder in the comics
ezra small
and to me waist disposal is a nod to dc
comics writer bob toomey now in martha's
childhood photo of clark his school is
weisinger elementary named after
superman editor mort weisinger who for
the comics developed the concept that a
yellow sun enhances superman's abilities
and notice how clark's science fair
project is a volcano
interesting parallelism with a
kryptonian world engine machine which
the movie's designer deliberately made
to function with the seismic effects of
a volcano
the way volcanoes devastate the
surrounding land but re-fertilize the
soil to
allow new life to grow from the ashes
when one of the metropolis cars lifts
from the world engine you can hear
screams inside
a haunting reminder of the lives lost
with each of these
dead and when superman punches up
through the world engine on the other
side of the globe there is a brief
frame where the light and pressure makes
kavel's face look kind of like
christopher reeve's face though snyder
said that this was unintentional
it's just the way it looks it's not i
mean if it looks like that that's the
gods not me
yeah the gods huh the only god we pray
to is zack snyder's
convert superman officially chooses his
new home over the one he emigrated from
ripton had its chance
and fiora al knocks a dude out of the
plane and he lets out a wilhelm screen
but colonel hardy kamikazes them with a
callback to her earlier threat
a good death is its own reward a good
death
has its own reward now the world engine
gravity has flattened a plane in the
middle of the city which is later
rebuilt into heroes park in batman v
superman and in justice league superman
fights zod first here and he fights him
again
in the same spot when zod's corpse is
resurrected as doomsday in the next film
and in justice league the rest of the
team fights resurrected superman
in the same spot superman's fight with
zod is filled with cool visual details
that are kind of hard to spot through
all these 911 reminders so let's break
them all down in a
breaking metropolis breakdown the wizard
fires up his heat vision for the first
time in that wrecked office on the desk
to the left of superman if you look real
closely is a poster in the style of keep
calm and carry on except this one says
keep calm and
call batman batman vs superman shows how
at this moment
batman was just blocks away helping
civilians survive this kryptonian bart
bite
as zod slides the lexicorp fuel truck at
superman in the bottom left corner
is a blood-stained smiley watchman logo
another nod by snyder to his past film
and then when they fly toward each other
on the building facade
in the background below is a sign for
blaze comics
an in-universe comics publisher that the
character booster gold uses
to promote himself they fly up to the
elects court building under construction
and zod forces superman into the days
without accident sign which
drops to zero superman punches zod again
and again through the air visuals from
storyboard artist j
oliva who cited anime series like dragon
ball z and birdie the mighty but after
that first hit on the far right the red
sign at the top of the tower reads
star labs the company where silas stone
turns his son victor into cyborg in the
next movie the air fight also
zips him past wgbs news which in the
comics is run
by superman foe morgan edge there's a
really cool visual when zod swings
superman around by his cape
no gapes the frame pushes in on zod's
eye which
transitions into superman's house of l
sigil from his chest as it flies away
the father and son who would spell zod's
doom they fly past the utopia casino
which in the comics is run by tony gallo
who smuggles in kryptonite into the city
four likes to use as a ring
and then up in orbit zod throws a
satellite which if you look closely at
it
is owned by the wayne corporation this
is the same satellite debris that bruce
sees
in the batman vs superman prologue when
he glares up at the man of steel from
the wayne tower rubble
honestly one of my favorite batman
moments and next up in our dc week we're
gonna crunch the numbers to rank
batfleck with all the movie batman in
big question be sure to check it out but
here the debris reigns past the old
lexcorp tower and it tumbles the two
brawlers down into the train station
where superman does
this
[Music]
see that shockwave after breaking zod's
neck that's what broke all of our hearts
and superman's heart
[Music]
see superman had to kill zod here
because azad said he was never gonna
stop trying to kill as
many innocent people as he could zod was
never gonna give up he represented the
extremist side of plato's republic
he wanted an idealist utopia where
society would be sorted but that
perfection was never meant to be
and you can see that in the crumbled
greek columns around them
reflecting the collapse of those ideals
and in destroying his homeland's old
guard
kal-el pays respects by kneeling before
zod
superman rex swanwick's surveillance
drone and captain ferris accurately
observes
i just think he's kind of hot carol
ferris is in the comics the love
interest of how jordan green lantern and
goes under the name star sapphire clark
gets a job as a reporter for the daily
planet the
man of steel assimilating as a man of
earth and lois underscores this
immigrant story with excellent wordplay
in the final exchange
welcome to the planet glad to be here
lois
our dc analysis will continue with a
re-watch and breakdown of zack snyder's
batman v superman donna justice and
we're going to look at the extended
ultimate edition because that's really
the only way to watch in my view
our live watch party will be wednesday
august 19th 5pm pacific exclusive to our
patrons on discord and you can join us
at patreon.com
new rockstars then our video breakdown
of batman vs superman will come out on
the channel
next friday follow me on instagram
eavoss follow new rockstars and
subscribe for breakdowns of everything
you love thanks for watching and always
remember to tip
yeah [ __ ] don't forget your tip
[Music]
you